'Kay. Here's, here's an example of, of cascade events or
broadcast events from Harel's paper. In this case, there are three concurrently
executed machines labeled A, H, and D. And there are transitions between them.
On some of the transitions there can be an action taking place and
that follows the slash. The actions that we've seen so far you can think of as
being equivalent to method calls in our object-oriented class model diagrams.
But they could also be the issuing of another event. For example in in,
in state A, there's a transition between substate C and
substate B that the transition itself is labeled with F.
But then there's a slash, which says if I'm taking this transition,
also issue a new event called G. That is, we've cascaded the event.
Now, the events themselves are globally known. So the issuing
of the event g here is known to the other machines in the concurrently executing
state chart. And this process of cascading the events can go on